TRUMP CLAIMED WAS GOING TO BE
THIS MAJOR ANNOUNCEMENT.
SOME SPECULATING MAYBE IT HAD TO
DO WITH THE PRESIDENTIAL
COMPANY, OR THE HOUSE SPEAKER
FIGHT.
NO IT'S A STORE TO SELL $99
DIGITAL TRADING CARDS OF
HIMSELF.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MOCK HIM ON
TWITTER LISTING HIS OWN
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
JOINING US IS JOHN AVLON AND
ERROL LEWIS.
I TALKED TO PEOPLE IN TRUMP'S
ORBIT ABOUT THIS.
THEY WERE EVEN LIKE WHAT?
PEOPLE THAT WERE NO LONGER HIS
ALLIES THAT DEFEND EVERYTHING HE
DOES, THAT --
>> EVEN PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION
ARE SAYING I WENT TO JAIL FOR AN
NFT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHAT IS THIS?
AN NFT?
>> IT'S ANOTHER CHEESY GRIFT.
HIM TRYING TO MONETIZE HIS HARD
CORE SUPPORTERS SHOWS HOW
UNSERIOUSLY HE'S TAKING THIS RUN
FOR PRESIDENT AND HOW
UNSERIOUSLY HE TAKES ANYTHING
EXCEPT HIMSELF AND EVEN THAT
TURNS INTO A CARTOON VERSION.
THIS IS MORE NONSENSE.
IF THIS IS THE BIG REVEAL SOME
FOLKS NEED.
LET'S BE CLEAR, IT'S NOT THAT HE
GOT BAD ADVICE HE IS BAD ADVICE.
>> LISTEN TO WHAT STEVE BANNON
SAID ABOUT IT BECAUSE I THINK
THIS ENCAPSULATES REACTIONS FROM
EVEN ALLIES.
>> I CAN'T DO THIS ANYMORE.
HE'S ONE OF THE GREATEST
BUSINESS PEOPLE IN AMERICA.
BUT ANYONE IN HIS TEAM, WE'RE AT
WAR, YOU OUGHT TO BE FIRED
TODAY.
I STILL DON'T THINK THIS GETS TO
THE HEART OF IT.
YOU DON'T HAVE THREE HARDER
CORES.
>> IF THEY'RE CRITICIZING YOU.
>> LOOK, STEVE BANNON HAS BEEN
SENTENCED TO PRISON, HE'S
SUPPOSED TO SPEND TIME BEHIND
BARS FOR DEFENDING TRUMP AND SO
DISRESPECTING -- WELL, THE
CHARGE IS CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
HE REFUSED TO GIVE ANY
INFORMATION TO THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
SOMEBODY WHO BATTLED FOR TRUMP
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND WHEN HE SAYS, SOUNDED TO ME
LIKE HE WAS THINKING OUTLOUD, I
CAN'T KEEP DOING THIS.
THIS IS NOTHING TO DO WITH ANY
CAUSE.
NOT EVEN WINNING POWER.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO DECLARED
FOR PRESIDENT IN MID-NOVEMBER,
HAS HE DONE ANY EVENTS?
NO, NOT DONE ONE SINGLE EVENT.
>> BUT PUT OUT SUPERHERO TRADING
CARDS OF HIMSELF.
>> EVERYONE THOUGHT THIS WOULD
BE SOMETHING HE WOULD ANNOUNCE
AN EVENT.
BUT THIS IS A GRIFT.
>> OF COURSE.
>> HE'S RAISING MONEY ONCE AGAIN
FROM PEOPLE WHO CAN, QUITE
FRANKLY, DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY, RIGHT?
AND THEY'RE SENDING MONEY TO
HIM.
>> HIM PERSONALLY NOT HIS
CAMPAIGN ACCOUNT.
>> YES.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> HE WILL FLEECE HIS FANS UNTIL
EVERYBODY IS OFF THE --
>> WHEN IS ENOUGH ENOUGH?
WHEN DO PEOPLE SAY I'M DONE?
>> I WOULD SUGGEST BY THE WAY
WHILE BEPERHAPS ARE TALKING TO
SOME OF THESE FOLKS, SEND THE
$99 TO YOUR LOCAL SOUP KITCHEN
OR PEOPLE WHO NEED IT IN THE
HOLIDAY SEASON.
PEOPLE HAVE TO GROW UP AT SOME
POINT.
TRUMP AND TRUMP-ISM AND WHAT HE
MEANS TO THE COUNTRY IS ABOUT
HOW DO YOU REACT TO THIS PERSON
WITH THE VULGARITY AND THE
OBSCENITY AND THE THINGS THAT
TRUMP BRINGS TO THE TABLE.
ARE YOU GOING TO ACCEPT IT, FUND
IT, LOOK THE OTHER WAY OR MAYBE
JUST OPT OUT, WHICH IS THE
EASIEST THING TO DO AT THIS
POINT?
>> THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO I'M YOUR
FAVORITE PRESIDENT --
>> PUT ASIDE THAT HYPE, THIS
AIN'T NONE OF THAT.
>> YOU HEAR BANNON SAY ONE OF
THE GREATEST PRESIDENTS OF
AMERICAN HISTORY.
THIS GUY IS GOING TO BE IN THE
BOTTOM FIVE IF HE'S LUCKY.
THIS IS A GUY WHO TRIED TO
OVERTURN DEMOCRACY AND GRASP
POWER.
AND HERE HE'S FLEECING HIS
SUPPORTERS WITH A CARD AS A
SUPERHERO.
IT'S JUST ANOTHER CHEESY GRIFT.
>> ARE YOU GETTING SOME POPPY?
>> ARE YOU KIDDING.
THAT'S MY ONLY ADDITION TO THIS
SEGMENT, ARE YOU KIDDING?
>> YOU CANNOT BE SERIOUS.
YOU'RE THE JOHN McENROE OF THIS
SEGMENT.
>> EXACTLY.
>> WHEN YOU SAID ARE YOU
KIDDING, I WONDER WHAT PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY, RIGHT, THE BIG PART
BRINGING THE WORLD HOME IS OUR
TAG LINE HERE, I WONDER WHAT
THEY THINK ABOUT THIS.
>> THIS ISN'T NEW YORK, I'M A
MINNESOTA GIRL AND I'M LIKE THIS
IS BEYOND.
>> I WONDER WHAT YOUR FAMILY IS
THINKING?
>> WE'LL ASK.
>> SOME PEOPLE SAY IT'S TRUMP
BEING TRUMP AND MORE CARTOON
NONSENSE BUT A TIME THERE'S
SERIOUS THINGS GOING ON.
AND THIS IS A PERSON WHO'S
FUNDAMENTALLY -- THIS IS
CLOWNING HIMSELF AGAIN.
AND SOME HARD CORE SUPPORTERS
ARE REALIZING THERE'S NO THERE
THERE.
>> CLOWNING?
>> CLOWNING.
>> I THINK THE CONCERN IS HIS
CAMPAIGN, IT'S PRECISELY WHAT
YOU SAID.
IT WAS YESTERDAY -- A MONTH
YESTERDAY HE ANNOUNCED HE'S
RUNNING.
THEY HAVEN'T PLANNED ANY
RALLIES, ANNOUNCED ANY EVENTS.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WERE HOPING
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN OUTLINE
OF WHAT HIS CAMPAIGN IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE.
HIS OWN ADVISERS WANT TO SEE
THAT.
>> HERE WE ARE FIVE YEARS AFTER
THE FACT, STILL MAKING THE SAME
MISTAKE.
>> I THINK WE'VE WASTED ENOUGH
TIME.
>> WE GOT TO JUMP.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE THING
THAT IS NEED TO GET DONE IN
WASHINGTON.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT A BILL NEXT
ON THAT FRONT.
>> BY THE WAY, BIDEN IS WINNING,
TRUMP.
SO BETTER GET IT TOGETHER.
THANK YOU, ERROL, THANK YOU
JOHN.